NORA SWITHENBANK:
My name is Nora,
and I'm a partner development
manager on the Google Play
Games team.
I'm very excited
to be here today,
because I get to
speak about a subject
that I'm very passionate about,
and that's live operations
and how LiveOps can help
you engage your gaming
communities to create long term
player retention and value.
So, to kick off our agenda,
I'll start with a framework
to define live operations,
that way we're all speaking
with a common language.
Then I'll talk a
little bit about why
LiveOps has become so important
in today's mobile gaming
ecosystem.
But really you shouldn't
take my word for it,
and that's why I've
called in an expert.
Keith Alexander, the LiveOps
manager for Kabam's smash
hit "Marvel Contest
of Champions."
He'll be here to tell you about
Marvel's best in class LiveOps
program, and also to give
you a few tips for running
engaging live ops
events in your games.
So, what is LiveOps and
why is it important?
Put very simply, LiveOps is
running games as a service.
This means that your games
become a living, breathing,
organic product that
is constantly changing,
giving your new users a
brand new experience each
and every single day.
The goals of LiveOps are to
augment engagement, stimulate
monetization, and
prevent player churn.
So, let's dig a
little bit deeper
into how to actually
achieve these goals.
As you guys are already
aware, content is king.
New content is what keeps
your players actively
playing and actively
spending in your games.
The players who devote
the most time in your game
become your loyal fans
and your best advocates.
These are the players who
have higher retention rates
and higher session frequency.
Now, Kabam, has lovingly coined
these players the regulars,
but for all you
Norm Peterson fans
out there-- anyone who
knows what "Cheers"
is-- it's the Norm Petersons.
High engagement and
retention are the keys
to creating long
term lifetime value,
because in the world of
mobile gaming content is king.
And that means that time
on device equals money.
Your most active
and engaged players
are more likely to
have higher LTV curves.
So, another way to
think about LiveOps
is the strategic distribution
of content through time
limited sales and events.
Now, when we talk about content
in the context of LiveOps,
we're not talking about large
APK updates and client side
features.
It can be small,
server side changes.
For example, adding
a weekend tournament,
or temporarily changing the
drop rates in a dungeon,
introducing a brand
new hero character
or a new piece of legendary
gear into your gaming economy.
This new content is
delivered in mobile games
through two different
channels-- sales and events.
When you sell content through
a gotcha or IAP bundles,
you drive monetization metrics,
such as new buyer conversion,
or ARPU.
But using content as the chase
prize in a competitive event
can help you drive
engagement metrics like log
in velocity or session length.
Making small server side
changes to your game
or strategically cadencing
small pieces of new content
that are hidden within
your large APK updates
keeps the player
experience fresh.
But why is all of
this important?
Kabam's CEO, Kevin
Chou, recently
wrote an article for
GamesIndustry.biz describing
the mobile game revenue curve
that he calls the shark fin.
This occurs when
a mobile game is
released without a consistent
pipeline of content
to keep users busy.
As you guys know, mobile
gamers love to consume content,
but they also get
bored really easily.
All your new content is
bundled into large APK updates,
but releasing that
content all at once
leads to rapid
content consumption.
Once a player runs through
all the new content,
they eventually get bored and
then churn out of your game.
This means that each
of your new updates
is reaching fewer
and fewer players,
and the revenue bumps that
you see from these new updates
diminish over time, creating
these smaller and smaller shark
fins.
In his article, Kevin
points to LiveOps
as a way to minimize
this revenue degradation.
LiveOps limited time
sales and events
can help you slow
roll the content held
within your large APK updates
and thereby helping you avoid
the shark fin, and
instead helps to drive
a steady and consistent
heartbeat of revenue.
But it's also important to
note that LiveOps is not
about short term revenue gains.
When executed properly,
the strategy behind LiveOps
is to engage and
retain your users,
to create healthy long
term lifetime value.
So, to recap, LiveOps is
running games as a service.
It's a strategic distribution
of content through time
limited sales and events.
A consistent stream
of new content
will help you augment
engagement, stimulate
monetization, and
prevent player churn.
And, finally, a happy and
engaged gaming community
drives consistent
healthy revenue
along with higher LTV curves
to help you get the most
out of your UA budgets.
So, by now, you
guys are probably
ready to see some
real world examples
of these engaging
LiveOps events.
So, it's my pleasure
to bring to the stage
the LiveOps Manager for Kabam's
"Marvel Contest of Champions,"
Keith Alexander.
KEITH ALEXANDER:
Thank you, Nora.
Just getting your
game launched is
a huge achievement, often after
months and months of hard work.
But you're going to have to
keep it running after day one.
What will keep the players
interested on day 30, day 60,
a year?
Marvel is reaching its two
year anniversary next month,
and we have mountains of
more content and events today
than we did when we launched.
We're lucky to be working with
Marvel, an IP with decades
of history and a deep roster
of interesting characters
and stories.
We build many of our events to
tie-in with current story lines
or to create new ones in
collaboration with Marvel.
Running LiveOps is
like continually
adding to the story.
Some examples are
the characters we've
created with Marvel
like Guillotine, Civil
Warrior, and Venompool,
as well as the Contest
of Champions comic book.
Here are some examples
of past loading screens
showing events or characters
featured in the game.
We had a civil war event between
Iron Man and Captain America
over the summer.
We added Loki, who was
recently a featured hero.
We had a series of
quests where MODOK
tried to take over the contest.
And this month, of course,
we're featuring Doctor Strange.
"Marvel Contest of
Champions," at its core,
is a fighting game with
fairly simple mechanics.
You dash in and out.
You have three
strengths of attacks,
and a few special moves.
But the team
continuously has been
working on adding new variations
through new buffs, mechanics,
events, and heroes.
It keeps the gameplay fresh
for our loyal players.
A great example
tying all of this
together is Ghost Rider, who
was just added to the contest.
He was featured in our
monthly event quest
for October called
Pandamonium Rising.
He has a new mechanic that
fits with his character called
judgments that have
different effects depending
on how and when you attack.
He's also more effective against
villains like Ultron or Venom.
A lot of work was put
into the art and design
to be authentic to the
original character.
We added a new mode-specific
boost for this quest
that players could use to
complete the event content.
We supported this
with a new splash
screen and a new special
event calendar as well.
Just by adding
this one character,
we can use events and other
small game changes to engage
players for an entire month.
So, let's break this
down a bit more.
Here are five tips
from the Marvel LiveOps
team on how to run a successful
and engaging LiveOps event--
the first, run a
variety of events.
Variety is definitely
the best way
to keep the core gameplay fresh.
The goal is to run
a variety of events
to engage different
types of players
and incentivize different
player behaviors.
Here are some examples.
We have arenas running all
of the time for those players
who want to compete
for top rewards
like four star featured heroes
or rare upgrade materials.
But there are also arenas for
mid-range players, for three
star heroes, and hero crystals.
So, it doesn't just
cater to the top veterans
but a wide range of players.
This was one of the very
first events in the contest,
and it promoted competition as
well as a deep champion pool
in order to succeed.
In general, events
with competition
often do better
than events without
a competitive component.
So, if you're limited on
the events that you can run,
start with a competitive one.
And this is shown
in the above stat.
Players who compete
in arenas tend
to complete a lot more
fights than those who only
do quests or alliance events.
Arenas are more competitive
and can motivate players
to participate in more fights.
Anyone at any phase of
the player life cycle
can go on quests.
These are maps with a variety
of opponents the player needs
to defeat in order to progress.
The main story quests are
increasing in difficulty,
and we also have
monthly event quests
with four difficulty levels.
Players can choose which version
they want to attempt and earn
rewards respective to the
difficulty they complete.
These come out monthly,
kind of like a comic book.
Over 20% of monthly active
users complete at least half
of a monthly cost.
This might seem like
a low percentage,
but it includes new
players who are more
interested in the main story.
We can see from our data that
a constant stream of quest
content improves the
retention of our regulars,
and it is one of the
main reasons we continue
to build them each month.
Alliance quests are also
a huge part of our game.
Players work together
with their alliance
to complete a quest map.
These maps can have
challenging bosses
with much more powerful
buffs, requiring coordination
from all members of the
alliance to complete.
But together, they can earn
some of the best upgrade
materials in the game.
Many of the events are launched
server side rather than built--
rather than based
on a build or APK.
The game configurations
control pretty much everything
within the game.
We use them to update the daily
quests with additional shards
and fragments earlier this year,
as well as randomizing some
of the enemies and ambushes.
We can create and send messages,
launch new quests and events,
and add new sales or
promotions at any time.
Our daily log in calendar is
controlled in the same way,
allowing us to create
special event calendars
like the one for Ghost Rider.
This gives us a great
deal of flexibility
when planning our events.
And this speaks back to
what Nora was talking about
in avoiding the shark fin.
The more control you can give
your LiveOps team on the server
side, the more
content and iteration
they can do without
major build releases.
Periodically, we also add
special event content,
often linked to things going
on outside of the game.
We added factions during
our Civil War event,
which coincided with the launch
of "Captain America Civil War."
Players could choose to be on
Team Captain America or Team
Iron Man.
There were special quests
and buffs associated
with each faction, and
players could switch partway
through if they wanted
to earn both rewards.
Chloe's Warriors of
Awesomeness Challenge
was a series of tough
battles in an event
we did with Chloe
Bennet, the actress
from Marvel Agents of Shield.
And we've also done
versions of this
with Ming-Na Wen
and Clark Gregg.
And our newest event is a Doctor
Strange dimensional rifts,
adding portals to our
maps, in conjunction
with the release of the
"Doctor Strange" movie today.
These special events tend
to shake up the routine
and have your players
change their behaviors
for a short period of time.
Adapting to the
special event and then
adapting back to a pre-event
state, both adds variety.
Remember, variety isn't just
the type of event you run
but also who is playing.
Some players are very
into the PVP arenas
while others are into being
the best at completing the PVE
quest content.
Other players focused
on social events
like alliance quests
or alliance battles.
Different types of
players are going
to gravitate to different
areas of your game,
and variety is trying to ensure
there's something for everyone.
Now, we didn't launch with
all of these elements.
They've been built up
over the past two years.
Each layer we added was built
with the other layers in mind,
and many of the later events
we added were alliance related.
The social and
cooperative element
is an important part
of keeping players
interested in your game.
Cadence events to
maximize engagement.
Major events are
planned far in advance.
Some elements of "Marvel
Contest of Champions"
are sketched out
all the way to 2020.
We have an amazing
backend tool called Sparks
that allows us to automate a
lot of the staples of the game,
so many of the alliance
and solo events
are set up to require
very little of our time
to keep running.
That allows us to focus on
what variations or additions
we can add.
So, let's talk about an
example week in the game.
The arenas are constantly
running with feature hero
events running twice a week.
We release a new hero
every other week,
so one week it will be
for a brand new hero
and the other week it will
be for an older champion.
The idea is this
gives players who want
the new featured hero-- they'll
get a break every other week.
But we still have
some hardcore players
that want to win every
single arena no matter what.
Alliance events are
run with seven, three,
and one day durations.
The seven day Summoner
Advancement event
starts at the same
time every week,
but the three day events
are on a 12-day rotation
and the one day events are
on an eight-day rotation.
These events have
different goals
and drive different
player behaviors,
but the staggered rotations
mean that the events will
stack up differently each week.
Alliance quests are run every
eight days-- five days on,
three days off.
During this time,
alliances compete
to move up brackets
and earn better awards.
The alliance versus
alliance battles
are about two days long.
And, in general, alliances can
complete about three a week.
Both of these modes
use champion lockouts.
That means champions
used in these events
will not be able to be
used in other modes.
This expands the champion
pool a player needs in order
to participate in
all of the content.
You can't just use your one
best character or one best team
in every mode in the game.
Every month we add
a new event quest
that players can complete.
This quest usually includes
two or three of the heroes
that we plan to release as
a way of introducing them
to the players.
Last month, it was Ghost
Rider and this month
it will be Mordo
and Doctor Voodoo.
Our fastest players can complete
heroic and mastery difficulty
versions of this quest in
about six to eight hours.
And if they're the
top 100 fastest,
they will earn extra rewards
and a legends title in the game,
so we have quite a few players
striving for that goal.
In addition, there are
the special event quests
like the Chloe quest,
and every day we
run daily quests for
upgrade materials.
Finally, solo events-- we
added these in the past summer.
These are shorter events players
can complete on their own
with 22 hour and
seven hour durations.
These are different in
that they're random.
They're pulled from a
pool of possible events.
Each time an event
ends, the player
won't know which
event will occur next.
If you're looking for
two events to stack up
like the 22 hour general level
up event and the seven hour
class specific level
up event, you're
going to have to keep logging
in and checking the game
to see which events are running.
But if you find a situation
where both are running,
you can double up on rewards
for the same amount of effort.
The schedule is
packed full of things
to do each week to keep even
our most voracious players busy.
The players who enjoy
your game the most,
the ones who are most
invested are usually
the ones that will complete
your content first.
Keeping them happy with new
content on a consistent basis
is a key factor in
retaining those players.
Reward players based
on participation.
Different rewards from
different areas of the game help
spread out player activity.
We intentionally made
arenas the best place
to earn gold to
upgrade your champions.
Alliance quests are the best
place to earn late game upgrade
materials, and alliance
battles are a great way
to earn new heroes.
Spreading the different
currencies and upgrade
materials into separate
events means players
have to spread their resources.
And with the champion
lockouts I mentioned earlier,
this leads to players
needing to upgrade
multiple champions rather
than just their top five.
So, not only do
rewards promote variety
by getting players to
participate in different game
modes, it also
increases the value
of top champions and
upgrade materials.
Some types of rewards-- sorry.
Milestones give players
a clear goal to achieve.
They know how much
effort it will
take to reach milestone
five, and they
can determine if they
want to stretch and reach
milestone six.
But the very best rewards
are found in rank rewards
where the player must
compete on a leaderboard
with each other for top items.
That way, players
determine the ceiling
on the effort needed
to earn the rewards.
As the top players
increase in power,
so will their top scores.
We also use bracketed rewards.
This image is from an old
version of our alliance quest
brackets.
Doing well and
earning a high score
could move you up
to greater rewards,
while not doing quite as well
could get you bumped down
to a lower bracket.
This is an added
level of competition
as not only do you have to
do well on a given event,
you have to continue to do
well to maintain your position.
All of these are ways you
can reward your players,
but in general, a combination
of milestones and rank rewards
works best.
Milestones work well with
a broad range of players
while rank awards entice
the smaller percentage
of very competitive players.
We use data analytics to
look at the number of players
who hit each milestone
or rank reward,
and this helps us make decisions
on tuning and future events.
Think globally and localize.
We're continuing to grow Marvel
and reach additional markets
by adding more
languages to the game.
We've added Dutch and
Norwegian in October,
and recently added simplified
and traditional Chinese.
You'll obviously have a
hard time reaching players
who do not understand your
events and promotions,
even if they love your game.
With planning and a
great localization team,
you can greatly increase
the efficiency and reach
of your LiveOps by
improving your localization.
In addition to languages,
targeted promotions
based on region or holidays
could be very effective.
We've run targeted promotions in
countries like Russia, Mexico,
and Brazil, and for special
occasions like Ramadan.
"Marvel Contest
of Champions" runs
on one server, which means
all countries and time zones
usually get the same events.
When we added solo
events, we made them
22 hours and seven hours
so that the start and end
times would not be static.
So, where one 22 hour event
might start at 10:00 PM,
the next one will
start at 8:00 PM,
and the next one will start
at 6:00 PM, and so on.
The start and end
times for these events
change so that is more fair to
people in different time zones.
This is not always
possible with your events.
But when dealing
with global events,
it's something that you
have to keep in mind.
Collaboration between
great teams-- LiveOps
makes the events
happen in-game, but we
are lucky to have all of
these teams supporting us.
And I'll highlight
a few of these teams
on the next few slides.
Lifecycle marketing and
social media channels
can reach players
outside the app
and reengage lapsed
players by letting
them know there are new,
exciting events happening
in the game.
That means planning events well
in advance and LiveOps working
closely with these teams.
A combination of lifecycle
marketing, LiveOps, and data
analytics can make your
processes more efficient
and improve the effectiveness
of your messaging.
Remember, be relevant,
timely, and succinct.
Have a clear call to action,
show value and urgency,
and segment and
target your players.
Your community manager
and customer service teams
are the ones interacting with
your players on a daily basis.
They can provide valuable
feedback on events
and will be the first to let
you know if there are issues.
When we talk about
regulars, we're
talking about long
term active players
with a love for your
game, and these teams
help ensure your
players become regulars.
Teams helping extend your
reach are also important.
Marketing and
business development
help us work with our partners
like Marvel and Google Play,
increasing user acquisition
through Google Play
featuring or collaborations
with Marvel are very beneficial,
and often require
LiveOps support.
We have had some of our team
recently at New York Comic Con
to meet with players
and do interviews.
There was a giant booth
in the Marvel area,
and we set up a
special event battle
and gave prizes
from a prize wheel.
It was great for
the team to interact
with players in that way.
I've heard that
some of the players
spent most of their day
repeatedly coming back
to beat the quest so they
could take additional spins
on that prize wheel.
And, finally, a talented
development team
paired with insightful analytics
can create powerful results,
even if it's something
as simple as improving
your tutorial
completion rate by 1%.
If you keep improving
small percentages,
they will add up to big returns.
The data science team is
embedded with LiveOps.
Their dashboards provide
us with up-to-date KPIs
like retention, engagement,
and event participation.
Whenever we have a
question, we can go to them
and get an answer.
When we create new events,
it's often a joint effort
between the design,
LiveOps, and data teams
to build and tune the
event before it goes live.
LiveOps also works closely
with the design team
on any new features, ensuring
that the launch of the feature
goes smoothly.
But-- as any developer with
a live game can tell you--
things don't always
go smoothly, so I'm
going to tell a short story
about the Yolo incident.
So, one Friday evening,
we were surprised to see
a bright orange banner appear in
the game with one word-- Yolo.
And it seems that there was
an incredibly rare bug that
caused a test message to be
sent as an announcement rather
than a general chat message.
So, all the players
in the game are now
looking at the words
Yolo in bright letters
at the top of their screen,
and I am so, so thankful
that it was Yolo and not any
number of possible other words
or phrases that we could
have used for a test message.
The LiveOps team quickly
pulled down the message.
The QA team found the
problem almost immediately.
And our tools team fixed
the issue in under an hour.
Our community team quickly
messaged out to our community
that it was our mistake.
And by the next
morning, an artist
had created this wonderful
image-- which we posted it
on our Facebook
social media page--
where it became one of
our most liked images.
We were able to quickly turn a
negative into a positive thanks
to the whole team
jumping on the issue.
So, here's an extra bonus
tip-- versatile tools.
These are some things you
want in your backend tools--
flexibility.
You want to create a tool that
can build a lot of variations,
so that you can
iterate on your events.
Also, building in
features that allow
you to target groups of
players can help optimize
your promotions and sales.
Data tracking-- if you don't
track and log your events,
you're going to have a
harder time figuring out what
went right or what went wrong.
Willingness to
iterate-- and this
isn't just about
iterating on your events.
You need to iterate
and improve your tools
so that you can create
more sophisticated events
and promotions.
And one last point--
scheduling and automation.
Every December, the studio shuts
down between Christmas and New
Year's.
But rather than that be
a slow period where not
much is happening in
the game, Christmas
is one of our busiest
times of the year.
So, to do this, we build all
of the events ahead of time
before the break, then we just
push the events when needed
and ensure everything
runs smoothly.
If there are any
issues, we can fix
them all server
side without support
from the rest of the
development team.
By building this
kind of tool, you
can continue to launch
content to your players
in between builds,
but it requires
an upfront investment and a
commitment to maintain it.
We're constantly tweaking
and building upon our events.
As the game ages, so do the
players and their champion
teams.
Our data team provides
us with metrics
that help us analyze
players so we
can make informed decisions
with our events and our rewards.
So, when we're building
events, we start with a goal.
What are we trying to
accomplish with this event?
What kind of KPIs can
we use to measure it?
Can we build it
without client support?
If support is needed,
we can see if we
can get it added to
the product backlog.
But if we can build
it, we launch it
and we analyze how it does.
Did it do well or not?
Why?
How can it be improved?
If the event goes
really well, is there
a way to permanently add
this event to the game
or build upon it with
additional development support?
By adding more flexibility
and control into your tool,
you can increase LiveOps's
ability to iterate and improve
your events.
So, to recap, run a
variety of events--
competitive and social ones.
Cadence your events to maximize
engagement, reward players
based on participation,
think globally and localize,
invest in talented teams and
communicate, and, of course,
invest in backend tools.
One final example,
to wrap this all up,
is the new Doctor Strange event.
Players will earn currency
called dimensional shards
by participating in different
events over the next five week
period.
The more they participate,
the more shards they'll earn.
Using this currency,
they can open up
new dimensional rifts, which are
limited time quests with very
valuable rewards.
They can choose when they
want to open these rifts,
so they aren't locked to
any start or end time.
And this new event is the
result of the hard work
of countless talented
people all working together
so that the LiveOps team
just has to hit a button
and launch the event.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]